what about what makes people happy then
you looked at that
yeah so
uh
what makes people happy i've i've
i
there's i i've read like a thousand
studies on happiness and a lot of them
even ones that are really famous
i'm like
these studies aren't that good they like
interview like 100 undergraduate
students and they're like so what makes
you happy i'm like
like how how should i know that these
hundred undergrad students or anything
like anybody else you you're not like
doing experiments it's just was very
underwhelming
but there are these new projects which
are really cool they're called
experience sampling projects and they
basically ping people on their
smartphones
and they say
who what are you doing who are you with
and how happy are you and they built a
data set of like three million happy
points the biggest one mappiness george
mccarron susanna three million
uh data points
and
there are all these cool sites i get so
excited because i just as i said very
very nerdy so like rewind these studies
they're like people are happier the same
person do the same activities same
people happier when they're in nature by
a lake where they're happier when their
environment is beautiful or their
happiest going for a hike or having sex
is the number one happy activity and i'm
kind of like
i was telling my friends because i was
working on the chapter and i'm like you
know did you hear about this cool study
and they're like do we need scientists
to tell us this
like that's so obvious like all these
things that you're saying
are painfully obvious
and i think there's profundity in the
obviousness of the research on happiness
uh which is that
the things that make you happy like if
you look i have the happiness activity
chart from alex bryson and george
mccarron in one of my and that's what i
recommend people get as an iphone case
or hang it on your wall or whatever
and you look at that chart it's almost
like a chart from our hunter gatherer
days it's like
people are
happy like you know yeah having sex
taking walks hunting and fishing
uh gardening like just like these very
outdoors simple activities and the
things that are really low are these
like very modern things like waiting on
a line
uh dealing with a bureaucracy working
uh
internet social media very very low
computer games really really low when
you actually ping people how happy are
they they rank very low
i think it's good to keep in mind like
the simplicity of the things that make
people happy and if you're not happy
uh oh i end the book i say what's the
data-driven answer to life uh based on
these three million you know happiness
points and and all this this new data
and i go the data-driven answer to life
is to be with your love on an 80-degree
and sunny day
overlooking a beautiful body of water
having sex
and like which is okay not rocket
science it's not like they
you know scientists have found
some like gel you put on yourself or
some website you visit that's like the
cure to happiness it's these very
old-fashioned simple things
and i do recommend
to people who are not happy
like think about how far your life is
from that those simple things that from
the data-driven ads for life so like
how much time are you spending in nature
how much time you're spending on the
internet in comparison uh how much time
are you spending with the people that
make you happy are friends and romantic
partners and like everybody else just
doesn't make you happy you had to
you had a list of underrated activities
the things that tend to make people
happier than they'd predict
exhibitions museums libraries sports and
exercise drinking alcohol gardening and
shopping or errands and then the
overrated activities that make people
less happy than they think sleeping
resting relaxing computer games watching
tv eating and browsing the internet i'm
surprised and i was really surprised
when i looked at the list of activities
that playing with pets wasn't higher
it's like maybe 15 i think but dude if
you put a dog in this room i'm not doing
anything for the rest of the day like
that's me that's me and the dog someone
oh you want to have some sex it's like
no sorry i'm with the dog at the moment
so again there's individual variation in
this
having sex with the person that no don't
do that so um drinking alcohol was an
interesting one and i think that you
talk about this it's not necessarily
just about what the activity does but
it's about what you're doing while
you're in the activity right so drinking
alcohol is often associated it's like
socializing you're spending time with
friends you're having a conversation
maybe you're also at a show or a comedy
event or watching a gig or something
like that
yeah i mean drinking alcohol what you're
getting with the pet example is there
probably is individual variation in
these and you don't have to
although i think a danger with happiness
is we exaggerate how much individual
variation there is so there have been
studies where they've they've compared
introverts and extroverts and they say
how much happier they are when they're
by themselves
or with other people
and both introverts and extroverts get
the exact same boost from being with
other people than being by themselves
even though if you ask introverts
they're like yeah yeah you know i really
like being by myself i really like being
by myself so i think there's a danger
like i
i'd be
i'd be a little wary if i were you like
i'd ask you to actually track your
happiness and see if you're getting as
much happiness from pets as you might
think because i think we do tell
ourselves these stories tell ourselves
these stories
that are
not always
correct and that we're like unique and
uh so i i i don't know i i mean yeah i
think there's also different time stem
with pets so sometimes like if you're
just like
you know right like
uh yeah like petting them playing catch
with them that's one thing if you're
cleaning up their
crap
well you've got it it's got to be spread
across time right one thing that i
thought that was interesting is there a
tension between happiness and meaning so
there's this roy baumeister study the
paper that you've probably read about
the tension that you have between these
two different things and there's a lot
of things that we can do in the moment
which makes us feel happy sort of more
on the hedonic side but long term
doesn't necessarily create meaning did
you think about this
i did like i think
uh
yeah you know like for example work
scores very low on happiness and i think
you know i don't know the answer from
that is just quit your job and
yeah live in nature okay so
living yeah i don't i don't and and you
know the the study that i referenced
mappiness uh isn't following people over
three years and being like you know
you see kind of the in the moment
happiness and you don't necessarily see
as much the
uh you know the long-term things
i do think it's just
it's just you i think from these studies
you just can nudge yourself a little bit
uh in the direction of things that make
people happy that that's kind of wise
without sacrificing everything that's
meaningful to you so don't you know uh
you know if you if you
read uh you know my don't trust your gut
or you read these studies uh i don't and
and then yeah you immediately quit your
job and move to a lake like i'd be like
that may be taking the advice a little
too
uh seriously i you know i
i
think think more clearly but anybody who
reads these studies and then
the next weekend is deciding between
sitting at home and playing computer
games
or going for a walk with your friends by
the water
and it is kind of uncertain like i'd
really recommend you went with your
friends on the walk by the water
uh just based on the data so
what did social media use due to
people's happiness you looked at that in
depth yeah yeah so so there so up in the
mappiness study
the single there are 26 leisure
activities
the single lowest
scoring leisure activity is using social
media
uh which already says wow that's
probably not so good for you and there
have been there was a famous randomized
controlled trial where they paid people
to stop using facebook
they randomly paid a group of people to
stop using facebook and they report an
enormous decline in depressive symptoms
so i think there really is pretty it's
almost a cliche to say it but there
really is evidence that social media can
make people miserable for the obvious
reason that
uh
it's makes you feel like crap about your
life uh you
uh you know if you're seeing on facebook
like the curated version of everybody
else's
life
uh i actually my first book everybody
lies i talk a lot about that and the
difference between like
social media and real life and google
searches and on uh social media when
people describe their husbands
it's my husband is the best the greatest
so cute and adorable
and that's like public everyone's seeing
it and when it's uh when there are
searching my husband is it's like my
husband is a jerk annoying mean uh like
a totally different people having sex
with me
not having sex with me yeah uh so
uh there's so like social media like
it's a cliche to say it but it's just so
true it really is a dangerous
uh game to play what's happening people
if you enjoyed that then press here for
the full unedited episode and don't
forget to subscribe
peace